GameSpot III day one proper really we
had press conferences yesterday
but today is all about the games and
we've got a game coming up next surprise
surprise and R it's gonna tell us all
about and welcome to the stage great to
have you on stage man thank you so what
are you here to talk about I'm going to
talk a little bit about terraria a game
that's been out for quite a while came
out originally on PC and then five or
five games took it to consoles to mobile
and now on this show we're for the first
time showing it coming to PlayStation 4
and Xbox one and we have a live demo to
look at live demo what we'll have some
so maybe discuss retail and a quick
introduction for the people that don't
know what terraria is terraria is an
indie game developer originally biologic
for PC and it kind of took the world by
storm not as much as Minecraft it but
pretty damn close to it and it's a
sandbox game where you can just walk
around gig build battle it has a lot of
different elements from similar games
that have been in the sandbox a radio it
it has boss battles and it's huge NPCs
that come over live with you Josh behind
the screen is Josh did a great job man
you keep going so what does it mean to
be able to bring this next to the next
gen ps4 it's just a natural evolution I
mean we'd be devoted to PlayStation 3
rubato to Xbox then a different studio
brought it to mobile so we have all
these pockets of community and terraria
has a very lively community it's a great
community and there's a real separate so
then we brought it to Vita embassy that
we had trans play with Playstation 3
fantastic you know suddenly you have two
communities bonding and that's well
really what we're trying to do with
bringing it to next-gen is not only
expand the community but also tie in
together such PlayStation 4 is going to
support full cross play with Vita
children play with the PlayStation 3
version and it's just that's what we're
trying to do and you know we've
implemented a couple of new features for
the PlayStation it's rendered in true HD
now which is this is freaking quite
so we are we added a zoom function
because if you want to build stuff like
like the base that you're going to get
in a demo that josh has it's going to be
too hard to do into HD especially if
you're you know we're sitting quite
close to the TV but if you're far away
ya know it gets really really tiny so if
you've never played before this is all
pretty intense what's going on here like
okay situation yeah Josh went up to my
battle arena which is basically just a
platform in the sky okay so you built
you built this earlier yes I built this
entire world as for the demo here id3
yeah took me about 30 hours to build so
I put quite a lot of time in yeah yeah
he is felling one of the endgame bosses
right now which is actually the only one
that comes all exclusive this this pass
does not exist in the receiver right
okay what is he what is he firing at
what is he firing a Josh is that he is
firing vampire knives which is a new
item we just came out with a 1.2 update
for the game on the existing platforms
yeah which added tripled the content it
has a thousand new items new bosses new
armor new crafting abilities so yeah
he's using one of the new endgame
weapons my personal favorite to fight
his endgame boss as I said which is the
control exclusive boss we're just lucky
that it's nighttime because you can only
pop the boss at nighttime I see yeah
yeah it's it's quite intense which was
just the definition of this game you can
play this game completely laid-back just
you know build a nice house build a nice
environment dig out build a lake or your
metal dude a skilled floating skill
crannies like him yeah and that's really
what gave terraria its its unique
community so a lot of people love
playing this while playing a multiplayer
with their buddies just pick on one of
these big monsters try and get all the
endgame gear for everyone so what else
is as a ps4 bringing this feels for
enables you to deal I guess in terms of
to have a scale of the world can you
build bigger whales that it's a very
good question it's actually a request
that we've been getting a lot from the
community okay if you see a slightly
bigger world's than the console versions
which is a memory thing the PlayStation
4 and the Xbox one are clearly capable
of rendering bigger worlds but we found
it more important to have our
communities being tied together and if I
do transplant have the world on my
playstation 4 be bigger than the one on
the playstation 3 because then your
cross plate wouldn't work anymore
yep so we kept the size of the world the
same but as I said Josh will show you
later when he's evil evil take a little
trip around the world it's already
incredibly big I know people are asking
for bigger worlds but it's much rather
have people being able to play together
yeah then then you know add a hundred
tiles to the left and a hundred times to
the right it's just not that interesting
where's he now is this a house you built
yeah this is my home but just replicate
your your real-life ice as well as you
love it I'm not quite I do have a
basement okay and this is built
completely on the ground I do have a
basement I usually do not lock people up
in there I've done yeah but yeah as you
can see in a madness eyes the world a
yeah it's completely on the ground it's
not even reachable without a teleporter
which is one of the new items that we
added in 1.2 okay and now we lost visual
oh I think we have lost our play role
for a minute there
nevermind oh no Barry are back very good
yeah he's gonna walk around the house
and then drop down which when you drop
down you'll really get a sense of how
big the world is because it takes a
pretty long time at the bottom like I
like your deck or here this is good flow
hey nice paintings what is that a
painting off what is that picture of is
that Poseidon pizza I think it's a lava
pool actress and lava pool looks like a
maybe - lava pit so don't be so little
it's my favorite and there are about 50
different paintings in here made by the
various pixel artists that worked on the
game actually - in there and I make
myself oh wow celebi's now josh is going
to drop down oh that's gonna make sure
gives me time to drink water
jeez everybody Phil watch no gun still
following me that's one of those that's
one of those bulls it would take quite a
few breaths if I between your screen oh
there we go and this is not even rock
bottom this is just the platform I build
right before the bottom because you
don't want to fall in the pool lava yeah
no that's never good armor I never knew
there were armored skeletons stand
Awards the middle the earth
well the more you know this world is in
the heart mode explain terraria has a
normal mode that you start in once you
progress through enough bosses it goes
to heart mode which makes the game much
much harder and I'll show a lot more fun
yeah it basically changed it changes the
entire game again
so I how do you normally plan in are you
more of a peaceful terraria player or a
dee-lighted you know as Josh's here at
all right tell us some trouble get some
face I usually go through everything go
through the bosses and then I'll take my
materials and just spend hours on our
building I'm more the building type of
player did you have to our air here like
on ps4 a t-34 for attendees to have a go
at or you knew just showing it off 505
games they showing it behind closed door
in their meeting room for media so
everyone can come late and play it's not
on the show floor yet because we didn't
quite feel that the built was ready for
that yet
but yeah it's up there it took up at the
Vita so you can cross play with Vita and
yeah it's maybe are we gonna see more of
this mini games come this year or do you
have any plans for you you use purchase
books Tony three right now I guess right
now plus that's a photo kind of what 505
games wants to do with it if they want
to show it at Gamescom the xbox one
build will be there but that's not to
them III not involved in those plans
well I just make the cool we roll well
I'm just glad but just glad you came
here today on our stage is show that off
thank you so much those great seats are
running on ps4 it's been a pleasure to
have your stage roof thank you and guys
don't go anywhere because we're gonna
throw over fir a news update because I
don't know what's going on today I've
been here so let's go over to Jess for
Annie's update
you